et le gobie de 19 et la vaccination au
programme du conseil des ministres ce
matin une rentière une rentrée avec des
chantiers à venir qu'ils sont nombreux
on va faire le point tout de suite avec
notre reporter katia technique devant
l'elysée
[Musique]
katia bonjour alors quelles thématiques
peuvent être abordés lors de ce conseil
des ministres
mais bien c'est une rentrée chargée une
rentrée des ministres après trois
semaines de congés des dossiers
importants sont sur la table avec
évidemment l'optique de la
présidentielle dans huit mois en premier
lieu évidemment la campagne vaccinale
sera discuté le gouvernement dans un
contexte qu'on connaît un d'opposition
au pass sanitaire veut éviter d'imposer
de nouvelles restrictions et donc il
doit faire la preuve que ces mesures
portent leurs fruits et d'ailleurs
soixante pour cent des français ont déjà
reçu leur dose 2 donc de ce côté là la
couverture vaccinale est plutôt bonne
mais la tranche des 12-17 ans n'est pas
assez vacciner et donc des inquiétudes
pèsent sur la rentrée scolaire le
gouvernement veut donc continuer à
inciter les français à se faire vacciner
avec la question de la troisième dose
dont on vient de parler pour les plus de
65 ans et une campagne de vaccination
pour les plus de 12 ans va être mise en
place dans les établissements scolaires
autre sujet d'importance et bien la
situation économique qui connaît une
embellie le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire a annoncé des chiffres en début
de semaine une hausse de la consommation
de 15 % pour les quinze premiers jours
d'août et une prévision de croissance de
6% pour 2021 il a annoncé également un
plan d'investissement qui va suivre le
plan actuel de relance et les ministres
ne manqueront pas d'aborder un sujet qui
fâche évidemment celle des réformes
alors celle de l'assurance chômage qui
va rentrer en application le 1er octobre
elle va diminuer les indemnisations pour
les travailleurs les plus précaires les
travailleurs à temps partiel évidemment
la réforme des retraites alors il
s'agirait de ne pas la mettre en place
emmanuel macron l'a promis pas la mettre
en place avant que la situation
épidémique tant qu'elle sera pas sous
contrôle et tant que l'embellie
économique ne sera pas là lors pour les
indicateurs économiques ça va pour le
reste c'est à suivre et les partenaires
sociaux vont être reçus par jean castex
le 1er et le 2 septembre pour en parler
en effet il faut quand même on le sait à
quel savoir que les syndicats sont tout
à fait opposés à cette réforme des
retraites avant les élections
présidentielles et puis sur fond de
crise en afghanistan emmanuel macron
sera amené peut-être a détaillé ses
efforts pour accueillir les réfugiés
afghans on sait que ses propos sur les
flux migratoires incontrôlés avait
froissé une partie de la classe
politique
aujourd'hui un élan national et
international est née élan de solidarité
pour l'afghanistan donc il sera
certainement amené à préciser sa
position merci beaucoup catia pour
toutes ces précisions katia technique en
direct devant l'elysée à paris